[Music]
World of Warcraft has forever changed
the world of online gaming in the
mid-2000s it captured the hearts and
minds of millions of players when many
were worried that PC gaming might be on
its way out its launch shattered
expectations it set the gold standard
for MMO design and many features that
were revolutionary when the game
launched are now simply expected players
were introduced to the Blizzard take on
the MMO genre they kindled friendships
and began to expect more than just a
single box game from developers and Wow
was huge in an era when it became
socially acceptable to be what had
previously been taboo unheard for the
owners of the over 100 million accounts
that have logged in WoW is many things a
constant reminder of earlier days an
occasional dalliance when a new
expansion drops or a continued passion
for those who haven't it can be
confusing to hear others talk about it
but whether or not you've ever loved the
game it's story help shape an industry
it changed the way people thought about
success in video games and fought its
way into the cultural consciousness this
is the story of World of Warcraft the
world of warcraft would not exist
without warcraft featuring a war between
orcs and humans Blizzard Entertainment's
first realtime strategy game sold
100,000 copies within a year of its 1994
release and once several awards making
it the company's first massive hit
Warcraft 1 was such a hit that Blizzard
really became a known developer
everybody the industry went wow became
game of the year and that raised a lot
of eyebrows and the second year they
weren't any longer the new kid on the
block Warcraft was not the first RTS but
it managed to carve out its own niche
the characters in its story were
compelling and the game's single-player
campaign was written to weave together a
coherent narrative about the game's
world at large the setting was
undoubtedly fantasy but with its own
high magic touches humans dwarves and
elves fought orcs ogres and trolls but
planets spanning portals and demons also
coexisted with no mission goblin
technology while crusading paladin's
clashed with unholy death Knights that
world was increasingly the brainchild of
Chris Metzen who had been hired in 1993
by Blizzard to provide art I remember
this was hundreds of years ago a chap by
the name of Chris Metzen came in and he
walked into my office and he noticed
that I had a lot of D&D stuff on the
walls and so he and I were immediately
connected there geeks I put you know
some of my drawings down on the desk and
he went and got the boss guy named Alan
Adhem and he invited me back we talked
for a little bit and he asked me if I
wanted a job and I told him that I would
sweep his floors you know I just knew
that the place I'd walked into and all
the people that I met that day like that
was you know it was it was home and by
Warcraft 2 Metzen was not only
fighting the art for the series but
helping to shape and define the world in
which it was set and as the conflict on
Azeroth expanded in Warcraft 3 so too
did the digital worlds geography and
medicine was made the game's creative
director all the artists you know we
played Warcraft 1 Warcraft 2 but we had
all these questions about the world so
we bugged Chris so much he broke out
these acrylic paints we looked at him
and we're like what are you painting and
he painted a map of Azeroth on the wall
it was his way of saying guys this is
the map of the world he just did it
Warcraft 3 and its expansion the Frozen
Throne were also critical and commercial
successes but so far Azarath had only
been seen from above from the generals
of U we dreamed about bringing Warcraft
to life so instead of being the top-down
realtime strategy game who would
actually just be a character running
around and and battling and teaming up
with your friends to fight increasingly
difficult bad guys that was sort of a
dream that wasn't really in reach until
really until Origen came out with Ultima
Online online RPG's had existed in
different forms including text base and
multi-user dungeons for some time but
when Ultima Online released as the first
MMORPG in 1997 it gave many including
Blizzard a look at what online gaming
could eventually become blizzards
employees were watching I remember
installing it on my work computer
expecting that I was just gonna take a
quick look at it I ended up staying all
night long playing Ultima Online and
never left my office chair and never
slept that night the MMORPG formula was
further expanded by games like EverQuest
Blizzard began development on World of
Warcraft even as work on Warcraft 3
continued announced in 2001 the game was
internally scheduled for a 2004 release
and the goal was familiar takers on row
with clear potential and give it
widespread appeal that meant a more
intuitive game with a clearer sense of
direction which in turn meant guiding
the player through the leveling
experience that required quests from the
moment the player was logged in until
they achieved max
instead of expecting players to find
enemies and grind by killing them before
moving on to other foes but that was a
massive undertaking I never in a million
years dreamed that we build the bones of
a world and the hills and trees and
rivers I don't think anybody had any
idea really how many people or how much
time it was gonna take to make world of
warcraft people started to realize okay
if we're really gonna hit these goals
we're gonna have to add more people so
the team started to grow we realized our
estimate of doing 500 quests just isn't
gonna cut it
we're gonna have to do like five times
that for this game to be awesome the
rapidly expanding blizzard team was hard
pressed to finish the game on time but
on November 23rd 2004 World of Warcraft
was released to the world World of
Warcraft's beta tests had shown solid
interest from players after Warcraft 3
they wanted more of Sylvanas more thrall
more Jaina
but even Blizzard couldn't account for
just how much people wanted more of them
we got off the freeway and there were
police everywhere there are crowds of
people walking down the street it looked
like Mardi Gras really was this moment
that United people who denounced the war
effort yes franchise seized this
excitement for the enemy genre really
opening up what had been a relatively
niche genre to the broader audience of
gamers from all walks of life all ages
all backgrounds it became something of a
cultural moment day one we were actually
shouting for correct numbers because the
numbers that were coming in were so
large that we thought that they were
incorrect numbers and that the
monitoring that we had in place was
bogus the technical side of providing
servers had been carefully planned but
all those projections went out the
window one of the things they felt
really really strongly about was not to
sell more boxes of the game than we
could support on our servers that we had
at the time because they didn't want
people to have a bad experience where
the servers were bogged down he couldn't
login and it turns out all of those
boxes that we had projected to last for
a couple of months sold out within a day
or two
blizzard may have been watching Ultima
Online in 1997 but in 2004 the rest of
the gaming industry was watching
Blizzard and those who logged in found
themselves with a whole new perspective
on
with beautiful vistas in a vibrant world
engaging combat and questing and social
aspects that were simply brand-new to
most players world of warcraft pulled
players into an expansive fantasy world
where they were the heroes confronting
everything from bandits to dragons with
sword bow and spell what lay over the
next hill or in that cave was a mystery
it was adventure that defined the player
experience what did you do in World of
Warcraft in 2004 whatever you wanted not
only were a lot of people playing the
game but they were paying a monthly fee
to do so Wow would go on to hit the
million player mark within a few months
it was truly amazing is how big a
success it became I think that caught
everyone off guard I mean we all thought
okay you know hey this thing could get a
million players here you know I mean
this is this is really special but when
it went up to 5 6 8 9 10 million
worldwide it was just just unbelievable
Wow his widespread success had more than
just a commercial impact despite some
early issues with server capacity the
game was well received by fans many of
whom found the combat and world more
engaging than previous games in the
MMORPG genre but once they leveled their
character from level 1 to 60 the game
became balanced around group content
that meant player versus environment
content like dungeons and 40 person
raids but also player versus player
activities like battlegrounds and world
PvP with their friends and often
complete strangers players in World of
Warcraft were forced to find allies if
they wanted to tackle the game's
toughest content the game's in-game
organization the guild became the
primary method for finding them Kois
communication servers sprung up to
support the level of organization needed
to overcome challenging raid bosses I'm
coming up with 32.3 3 repeating of
course percentage of survival
a lot better than we usually do already
guys oh my god he just ran in David when
she stick it clean oh my god
god dammit Leroy fans compiled
information and strategies and created
an internet community around the game
hey guys and thanks for tuning in to
trade chat my name is Panzer Corps
normos and today's video is my opinion
on why World of Warcraft isn't going
anywhere anytime soon
he's Mulder Walker Freddie oh my name is
totalbiscuit and I have to fill two
hours with talk and general drivel
alright so Fenris quit the guild because
he ended up getting a job and a family
and some other worthless stuff well
being social and interacting with other
players had been a welcomed curiosity as
players leveled it became an absolute
necessity at endgame and that meant
players forged friendships online at a
time when that wasn't the norm this has
probably happened where players have met
online and then subsequently become
involved have you ever taken advantage
of that my wife would have Jack how did
you meet your wife those online bonds
would cross over into reality when
Blizzard held the first Blizzcon in 2005
at any Blizzcon the hotel lobbies
surrounding the convention ring with the
laughter of Gil Dee's meeting in person
yet again or for the first time to
celebrate their successes and perpetuate
inside jokes it was no longer just a
game or a hobby but a community I'm
going up the the escalator and as I'm
getting to the top I just yell hard and
the whole audience lights up
you hear - for the Alliance oh and they
just start you know raging on each other
how cool is that this is these people's
lives I mean they have some of these
people came from all over the country
all over the world to come together to
meet some of these players that they've
met in the game there was one other
thing that made wow such a massive
success upon its release in the
mid-2000s things that were nerdy or
slowly becoming well cool whether it was
film books or a wizard or gaming she's a
level 15 oven Rangers sort of the forest
and it was safer than ever to be a nerd
which meant more people logging into
Azeroth as players introduced their
friends to the game there was just one
issue you had to have a PC to play Wow
and PC gaming wasn't looking too healthy
at the time of Wow's release some were
already predicting that the next
generation of consoles would wipeout PC
gaming entirely though other Blizzard
games like Diablo or Starcraft also
played a role while was a big part of
the PC platforms continued relevance to
gamers during this time period
gamers built bought or begged for pcs so
they too could be part of Azeroth and as
the game continued to flourish
celebrities started to admit that they
too enjoyed World of Warcraft
I was playing world Warcraft at the time
and I had my priorities straight wait a
minute you were at home it's not like
you weren't home you were home but you
were playing a little Warcraft and the
phone rings and you're like I'll get
that later
oh quit the game for good going on a
year now which one
well the Warcraft Vin Diesel was a big
fan even playing it with Paul Walker in
this clip that's actually got me and Vin
Diesel became friends was I was on past
7 his sister found out that I play World
of Warcraft
and so like every night after
we would like to go over to his place
and like set up computers I'm like other
side of the room like okay we're gonna
go to this dungeon we're gonna go do
this
that's what Vin Diesel doesn't his
off-time - yeah
there are almost too many others to
count the late actor Robin Williams
apparently a big fan was even
memorialized in the game after his death
and Wow began to appear first on the
internet but then eventually in other
media has an actual cultural reference
instead of an offhand comment in an
interview this role-playing game out in
2004 returns to the world of Azeroth
where heroes like Leroy Jenkins do
battle and that would be the world of
warcraft as far as like he's a rogue
anon the mage I'm a part of the same
guild but secretly he's a work with the
Alliance to undermine us for the whole
horde Wow was having a moment and
Blizzard understood that leaning into
the game's popularity to make
commercials that featured actors you
wouldn't expect for a mid-2000s PC game
hello I'm William Shatner and I'm a
conduit of the ancient forces of nature
smack-talking fools been saying mr. t
can't change to world of warcraft
he ain't no computer hacker well ask me
this suckers how do you explain the
mahogany
there are 10 million people in the world
of water because Chuck Norris allows
them to live
I'm Chuck Norris and I approve this game
in China as Blizzard looked to expand to
the country's massive audience they even
made a commercial featuring pop idols
and famous athletes in partnership with
coca-cola
[Music]
and though the game had to have slight
visual modifications to comply with
China's laws about violence and blood it
was a huge hit in the years around
Burning Crusade this is when you really
started to see the adoption in Asia and
in Europe that made world of warcraft
not just an American phenomenon but a
global phenomenon the beautiful thing
about a game like World of Warcraft is
that it crosses cultures very well in
China for example internet cafes are so
popular it's always been a one-child
policy kids they don't they don't have
siblings so then they need to go to a
place where they can get that social
interaction it's it's an experience
emotional go away so you play the game
though well-received was not a static
entity it was a service content updates
would bring new challenges and
adventures to the player base while
patches were not unknown in the gaming
world these updates were substantial
chunks of content more akin to small
games on their own Blizzard would expand
on World of Warcraft with several
expansions each bringing new features
races and classes the first to the
Burning Crusade and Wrath of the Lich
King featured major characters from the
Warcraft 3 storyline as antagonists both
were well received and the player base
continued to grow throughout this period
as heroes confronted fan favorites like
Illidan and Arthas the third expansion
would be far more risky in late 2010
with the release of Cataclysm Blizzard
put the devastation of Deathwing in-game
completely revamping zones that had
existed in their original 2004 form the
dragon death wing would arise to not
only threaten players but destroy the
itself the craziest thing about this
franchise is that the world itself is
probably the most key character or
that's crazy right it's very very cool
so the powerful idea with Cataclysm was
what if we imperiled the world you know
as a vast
azeroth will break
but meet the shadow of my wing Cataclysm
was the first in a series of risks that
Blizzard took with the world of warcraft
it was the first expansion to be truly
controversial and the period immediately
before its release
represented the peak of the game
subscriber numbers the total crested 12
million the initial reaction to the next
expansion mists of pandaria
was worse released in late 2012 this
expansion attempted to introduce a new
asia inspired visual style to the game
alongside jovial yet martial pandaren
though many who had played the expansion
who testify that it was a step up from
Cataclysm and a unique adventure worthy
of the WoW name many others viewed it
with disdain and didn't even give it a
chance warlords of draenor brought
players to an alternate reality where
the whole world of the orcs had never
been destroyed but much of the planned
content for the expansion was cut or
reworked and it featured a lengthy
period of time at the end of the
expansion where no new content was
introduced
now cut content is entirely normal in
game development and every expansion has
a large amount of it but with warlords
of draenor it began to encroach on the
core experience part way through that
expansion Blizzard released subscriber
numbers for the very last time revealing
a 5.5 million number in a 2015 earnings
call legion released in august 2016 was
a step away from experimentation and
towards iteration Illidan had returned
this time as an ally and he stood in
opposition to the demonic Burning Legion
well we don't have the subscription
numbers the game did experience its
highest number of concurrent players
since cataclysms launched and the game's
newest expansion battle for Azeroth aims
to continue that trend refocusing the
story on the age-old conflict between
the Alliance and the Horde a point of
pride for many players we want to create
amazing artwork or content or music or
stories or quests and to think that this
game affected people is awesome and
humbling we earnestly believe we're
making something special throughout all
of Wow's history the continuing story
has been a huge draw for players as
battle for Azeroth gets underway
Blizzard has a game continue the
storytelling for which they are famous
Burnage the controversy has sucked so
many old players back in while new
adventurers flocked to the banners of
both the Alliance
[Music]
and the Horde
[Music]
the game has adapted in a world where
streaming has exploded in popularity
Blizzard continues to support the game's
PvP arena eSports scene but perhaps
correctly guessing that the player based
skews towards PvE they've also added the
mythic dungeon Invitational one of the
really cool things about this being the
first time we are doing an eSports PvE
program in World of Warcraft is we'll be
able to see if there's any differences
under the pressure of the kind of live
environment but some players don't want
to adapt they want to go back to what
they felt in 2004 and Blizzard finally
has responded
[Applause]
of war Warcraft around the world we hear
you I am pleased and also a little bit
nervous to announce the development of a
classic server option with WoW now in
it's nearly 14th year it's hard to
imagine it reaching the subscriber
heights of 2010 over that time though it
has grossed over nine billion dollars in
revenue as of January 2017 and with
subscribers continuing to pay a monthly
fee Blizzard has shown no signs of
slowing down development for their title
as long as people play it will always
want to support this game we never see a
horizon there's really not precedent
that we can look to I think that we're
charting new territory there's no end to
the experience it's kind of one of the
beautiful things about it
battle for Azeroth the newest expansion
became the game's fastest selling ever
after nearly a decade and a half it
seems like the world of warcraft will
continue to exist as long as there are
heroes willing to defend it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button